rather than focusing on any singular
part of the industry not being rather
than focusing say on the retail or
consumers or investment trends we cast
the net completely wired to capture any
day to eat from any source feed it into
our system and start using that rather
than define where both our connective
tissue was within these data stands as
well as what the broader story you will
see energy was just done what we believe
to be the most comprehensive assessment
of global demand for cannabis in the
world today there are over 260 million
it's at least semi regular cannabis
consumers around the world who are
collectively spending over 350 billion
dollars each year on cannabis that does
not include all of medical applications
in Aboriginal culture pute accuses nor
does that include any industrial
applications are emerging with
activation of the industrial hemp I
believe that the legalization of
cannabis is going to be arguing the most
consequential social change of our
imagination we're now looking at over 60
countries just in five year round so the
pace is accelerating from African the
reason why it's moving so quickly is
because the science is affirmative
cannabis is largely or increasingly
being as seen as as acceptable if not
better than then that's part of the
reason why companies that Constellation
Brands one of the world's largest canvas
compared alcohol companies just spent
four billion dollars investing in the
Canadian license operator they see the
writing on the wall we use the public
placing reports that we really believes
as a way to signal to the market some of
the major issues that we think so the
data that we make available through a
courier which is our lady platform may
be the simple way to think about it
second Bloomberg of cannabis industry
houses not just the reports that we
produce but the data underlying the
report if you want to go in and explore
the day to yourself I can certainly do
that through that we developed my
cannabis consumer marketers
profiles of cannabis consumers that are
not just defined based on what they
consume and how they can
but based on all of these other
lifestyle attributes as well we would
all do well to find more joy in
ourselves and spark joy in each other
and I think that seems to be one of the
route that we're driving commitments
that's pushing a lot of people in this
space someone's opinion may contradict
yours where's my friend Allen it's all
about your perspective who are we if
what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on we're on site
at the beautiful new West Summit the
cannabis tech conference we are now
gonna be speaking with John Kaguya hi
John thank you so much for coming on the
show the pleasure's mine thank you I'm
so pumped for this those that don't know
John's background his chief knowledge
officer at new frontier data and he's
one of the first analysts to focus
exclusively on legal cannabis all right
John how who are you how did you even
get interested in this field so I'll
tell you I never in a million years
thought I would be working in cannabis
I'm a professionally trained market
analyst I become masters degrees and
business and in marketing research and I
built my career working just for small
market research agencies that were
working for very large generally very
conservative organizations Microsoft's
IBM's you offered prominence of the
world and we would work with these
companies to help them kind of address
and deal with respond to major strategic
operational challenges how to build new
products are gonna be serving the global
marketplace in late 2011 as we're
watching the run-up to Colorado's ballot
initiatives we're getting the signatures
ready and trying to get the vote for
legalization on the ballot again paying
attention to it because candidly I never
thought cannabis was good to be legal in
my lifetime
and just out of personal interest in
information junkie I started digging
into some of the early numbers that were
seeing in Colorado around support and it
became apparent to me that there was a
very good chance that this was going to
pause and that nobody was paying
attention to it and there was certainly
nobody providing the kind of market
research that we had been providing to
you know these world-class organizations
the kind of market research that you
find in every other sector of the
economy in what seems to be an
exaggerated economy that was about to
emerge so I proposed to my employers at
the time that maybe this is something
that we should look at and you know we
worked in Washington DC we had many
government clients and like not yet so
our compromise was that it becomes a
personal pet project I would report out
every three to six months what we were
finding and we'll make a goal go go go
go no-go decision on whether or not to
enter this space well fast forward four
years and every time I presented to be
like oh this is amazing by that point
Colorado's measure had passed Washington
legalized Washington DC had legalized
but but every presentation there like
this is amazing but we're not quite
ready and we're not quite ready yet and
I'm watching this market emerging and
watching the momentum building my mind
is being blown that this thing that I
never thought had any possibility of
happening is not happening so fast
forward to the summer of 2014
I'd actually just come back from an
extraordinary trip to Brazil for the
World Cup and I gotten back to
Washington in time to watch the World
Cup final and trying to decide where I'm
gonna go and watch this this game and
for some reason I felt compelled to go
to this restaurant that is not a place
you would ordinarily go to watch a World
Cup match there's a lot of great soccer
bars that it could've gone but for some
reason it felt like the right place to
go and and watch this this game and some
sitting at the bar sipping a cup of
coffee watching
matching the screen above the bar and I
get introduced to the woman who was
sitting next to me
unless he didn't Washington ask what she
does and she tells me she's about to
start a data analytics company in the
cannabis industry that's how much I
found Giada
why the car sir and it's been nearly six
years since we met and we hit it off
immediately we spent a handful of hours
that day geeking out at the bar and
she's like where have you come from
everybody else was open at the time you
were talking about cannabis people who
were in a run for the hills screaming
but there was just a clear connection
there there was almost immediate that
was immediate and as the conversation
continued as I began to understand what
it was she was doing it became clear
that this was just too compelling an
opportunity to pass on a total
Greenfield market mm-hmm that was
growing explosively that had no data no
meaningful data worth speaking about and
that was so well aligned with my
professional interests yeah so I firstly
joined the frontier in January 2015 and
had never looked back
what an interesting trajectory were you
also born in Kenya I was born and raised
in Kenya yeah moved to the US how old
were you I was twelve and a half when we
moved to the US so he did middle school
in high school here and then I went to
the UK for my undergrad and graduate
degrees yeah move back to Washington and
it's largely cold called it home sins
and doing data for all these other
massive companies and analytics and now
you saw the trend and it's so
interesting how the universe put you and
new frontier data at this like World Cup
final like you were going somewhere that
wasn't unconventional and it ended up
happening it's very interesting so okay
now how do you guys pick you know in
2014 these things are starting up you're
trying to you know find signal in data
is just something even in your previous
work that you were doing as an analyst
how are you how do you find signal in
data like structuring data is something
that we care a lot about that's what
we're doing we're identifying great
minds we're sitting down with them
butchering data sharing it with other
people in a sense but how do you pick
like how do we pick who to pick how do
you how do you pick the data which most
interesting to you guys so this is where
there's a science and an art to the kind
of work that we did one of the things
that I learned quite early in my career
and and had extraordinary mentors to
guide us through our early training was
that it's very easy to teach the
mechanics of research it's very easy
relatively to teach people how to crunch
the numbers and particularly now in this
highly technological environment there's
no shortage of solutions that can do the
vast majority of the work for you in
terms of just processing data what is
much more difficult to do is to explain
to understand and identify this so water
to understand and identify the
implications and tell a compelling story
around it and that's the art of research
that's the art of what we do why should
people care why should people care and
how can they use this to do what they do
better in the case like cannabis having
come from an environment where you know
our issue was actually generally we had
too much data we had too much
information coming to cannabis there was
it was not just the most data dearth
environment I'd ever been in it was the
most data averse environment I've ever
been in one of the first conversations I
had with Master Gore he told me that
he's been growing cannabis for about 30
years in California but at the end of
every cultivation cycle he'll burn all
of this no to all of his records because
he was so scared about federal
intervention about getting caught up by
law enforcement that he didn't want any
records of his historical practices so
you know coming from environment where
we're literally talking about billions
of data points into one where people are
writing things down on in notebooks and
then burning on it
of the season was just a complete flip
of kind of environment were in so as a
company we realized that this was not
going to be a conventional environment
in terms of the types of data stories
that you see in other ecosystems but
that also where we saw an opportunity
and rather than focusing on any singular
part of the industry not me rather than
focusing say on retail on consumers or
and investment trends we cast the nets
completely wired to capture any data we
could from any source feed it into our
system and start using that to identify
where both the connective tissue was
within these data stands as well as what
the broader story we're seeing emerging
was and what were those connecting
tissues and what is the broader story
that emerged so one is that for every
market we have seen legalized we have
seen explosive consumer demand and I've
been in the space for five years over
five years now and when I first started
I thought I knew how much cannabis
Americans consumed I had no idea
Americans have a prodigious appetite for
cannabis and you know one of the one of
the interesting things about this market
how much are we talking so the numbers
just sort of global contacts we've just
done what we believed to be the most
comprehensive assessment of global
demand for cannabis in the world today
there are over 260 million it's at least
semi regular cannabis consumers around
the world who are collectively spending
over 350 billion dollars each year on
cannabis so if the current legal market
is just around over 20 billion dollars
we have barely scratched that's worth
iceberg of the addressable market that
can be the full legalization will
represent assuming it became legal
globally and it's a trillion dollar
market or more yeah it certainly has
that potential because if we're talking
about a 350 billion dollar market of
just regular consumption
which is largely flour and generally
low-quality flour in most parts of the
world that does not include all of the
medical applications and the
conventional therapy it accuses nor does
it include any of the industrial
applications are emerging with
activation of the industrial hemp Wow so
the the long term opportunity that this
could could grow into has meant that as
my study of the industry has continued I
believe that the legalization of
cannabis is going to be arguably the
most consequential social change of our
of our generation yeah so it could be
that the industrial hemp and also the
health and wellness applications of
cannabis could themselves be
significantly larger than the
recreational use market on the legal
side absolutely at least initially
so first taking the medicinal side it
has been extraordinary to see how
quickly the global community has began
to have this debate conversation around
medical cannabis when we first started
looking at this industry you know there
were probably four countries around the
world where there was meaningful
progress or active legal programs we're
now looking at over 60 countries just in
a five-year window so the pace is
accelerating dramatically and the reason
why it's moving so quickly is because
the science is affirming it when the
World Health Organization comes out to
the statement with a very affirmative
statement about the wellness and
therapeutic benefits of CBD when the US
National Academies of Sciences through
the most comprehensive assessment of all
of the scientific literature around
cannabis comes out and says yes it does
work for paying for Northey related
cancers it does improve patient wellness
outcomes you know the medical community
which has so long been informed by the
propaganda of the war on drugs and
of prohibition is now being challenged
to rethink the rule that cannabis can
play and improving health and wellness
outcomes in our population and so that's
happening on a global basis and and even
amongst skeptics when they see the
effects that it is having on their
friends and their loved ones like so
many other issues once it hits home once
it becomes a kitchen table issues
attitudes change very very quickly once
family member has some sort of a health
issue and then it's all week changes
perspectives here on the industrial side
we think the the transition is going to
be a little bit different so because
cannabis and or because marijuana and
have got prohibited at about the same
time despite the long-standing
recognition that hemp was a preferred
nominally versatile plant it largely got
removed from our industrial economy so
for all of the innovations that have
happened across the industrial economy
I'm across virtually every other sector
of the economy over the past decade hemp
has remained a largely unexplored
unstudied plant and so the applications
that we are seeing people started to
focus on now whether it's bio plastics
and companies like BMW integrating hemp
based plastics into the interiors of
their latest models biofuels the hemp
produces a Kirkuk equivalent of light
sweet crude from four bioethanol
biodiesel textiles the fact that Levi's
have just announced their first hemp
cotton blend jeans and even though it is
a 70/30 cotton hemp we anticipate within
a few is it's a matter of time before we
start seeing a hundred percent hemp
products that are virtually
indistinguishable from from cotton
everything from paper to animal feed the
spectrum of applications that
construction materials yeah super
capacitors with hem with hemp so there's
a team out of Canada about two years ago
that did this study that found when you
carbonize hemp it produces a super
capacitor that can rival graphene and
graphing right now is one of the best
applications that we've identified it
produces a capacitor that can rival hemp
with none of the toxicity sorry a super
capacitor that can rival graphene with
none of the toxicity that is related to
the manufacturing of graphene now this
is early science still but consider the
possibility that you know the Tesla's of
the future could be running on batteries
that are based on based carbon these are
applications that we're just beginning
to explore and as you see increased
investment as more countries begin to
reintroduce having the economies the
pace of that innovation is going to
accelerate too dramatically and the
substitution of him for many existing
applications I think will grow across
the economy oh man you really showcase
this as the emerging market just yeah
just straight up the emerging market
like the other people argue that oh you
know blockchain crypto decentralisation
is like the emerging market but you're
like nah and they kind of go it they go
into mance in so many ways and and this
is not to knock either blockchain on
Krypton which are going to be massively
disruptive in the respective ways but I
think there's a number of things that
make hemp unique in where it sits in the
economy or what cannabis sits in the
economy one is just how disruptive it
will be in so many different aspects of
our society so let's just take some
social issues there's easy
considerations
prohibition forcement has been largely
very inequitable in the US you have
blood across the country on average four
times more likely to be arrested for
cannabis offenses if you were black than
if you were wise in Washington DC you
were eight times more likely to be
arrested if you were black in the wild
in fact we just had an event with the
mayor of DC last week and we ran some
numbers that found black males make up
22% of Washington's population but make
up over 80% of the arrests from our own
offenses there's been significant very
significant inequity in the way
prohibition has been enforced so with
legalization the ability to remediate
what has been a century of inequity
alone is going to be a dramatic social
impact because of prohibition cannabis
consumers have been driven underground
it has not you know ten percent of
Americans of just about 10 percent of
Americans consume cannabis regularly so
it has not prohibition has not stopped
they use it has just meant that it has
become a very segregated you know
isolated activity the fact that we're
now talking about cannabis social use of
spaces appearing in on Main Street
company called laurels just introduced
the Los Angeles's first cannabis cafe
it's gonna be radically disruptive to
our kind of notions of her academy sits
in our society yeah the medical
applications in the midst of a
catastrophic opioid epidemic yeah
when states like Illinois say that now
when your doctor or when a physician
issues you an opiate prescription you
automatically become eligible to
participate in the medical cannabis
program because they're so worried about
yeah propagating this opioid epidemic
you know these are just kind of
low-hanging fruit in terms of some of
the ways cannabis is reshaping some
long-standing
aspects of society like physicians
literally being educated on their MCAT
about cannabis in the endocannabinoid
system yeah that and the fact that
they're not mean and they haven't been
historically the doctors who were at the
vanguard of medical cannabis had to go
and study this themselves because it
wasn't being taught in in medical school
and so the all of those applications
that the all of those complications from
policing and social governance to
distribute ization and the normalization
of cannabis in our society are going to
be really consequential and the way we
think about where cannabis it's in our
society pulling will not thread a bit
more something like social use cafes
where cannabis is served but alcohol is
not allowed
you just sick straight up also just yeah
just ban that other one yeah nope can't
bring a beer and no wine in here
there's an extraordinary paper in the
british medical journal the lancet a
little while ago that showed it was the
largest global study on the impact of
alcohol on global public health yeah and
in the conclusion of that report the
statement that read the only safe amount
of alcohol to consume is none now even
the lead author would go on to say he is
going to have a glass of wine with his
dinner but you know there's a real kind
of recognition that alcohols had a
hugely deleterious effect on public
health around the world and now you have
class a cohort of young adults who are
growing coming into maturity at a time
and cannabis is largely or increasingly
being as seen as as acceptable if not
better than an alcohol the disruptive
impact that this could have on alcohol
and alcohols place in our society it's
potentially going to be very very
significant and that's part of the
reason why companies that Constellation
Brands one of the world's largest campus
alcohol companies just spent four
billion dollars investing in the
Canadian Mason
they see the writing on the wall yeah
and so when you take all of that and
then add on things like the industrial
applications of hemp the in my view the
implications of cannabis as an industry
I think extend well beyond what
something like blockchain or crypto
could do damn such a good synthesis on
the industry like love in it it's
obvious that new frontier has to do a
lot of deep dives into all of the
different profound impacts that the of
the Ascension of cannabis and hemp will
have on our world and and by doing so
you guys also become you know doing
these industry analyses gives you guys
unique foresight and so then companies
want to talk to you and they want to
know well where should we invest what
countries are moving forward what are
they moving forward with which specific
aspects are they going forward how are
Gen Z gonna be stepping into there you
know as ten-year-old seeing cannabis be
legal and also then as twenty year olds
when they have the option to consume
well what are they going to be choosing
how are we going to be leveraging it for
other spiritual ascension potentials and
right now it doesn't really seem like
alcohols being used for that whatsoever
so there's so much fascinating nuance
there do you guys end up taking the the
teach about this process do you guys end
up taking and making industry reports
and then taking those reports and then
distributing them through people that
subscribe to new frontier data right so
we have a number of approaches by which
we do our work because of the broad
spectrum of issues across the industry
that were tracking on data that we are
ingesting from companies in the industry
from governments of the
county state national level
international
organizations because some of the
partnerships we book we have this
constant and extraordinary stream of
data that's flowing across our data
engines so we use the public facing
reports that we release as a way to have
signal to the market some of the major
issues that we're thinking about you
know the given how much is happening in
cannabis we feel that one of the
privileges our rule has given us is the
ability to see what's happening next
what's coming next and for the
stakeholders who are either already in
the space and kind of heads down in the
work or trying to come into the space
and trying to figure out where they
should fit our work is our reports give
them a chance to understand where some
of the major issues that they should be
paying attention to lie within this
space but there's a second aspect to our
work which is the custom research that
we do so there's a lot of companies who
will see something that we've talked
about in a report and then engage us to
do some specific analysis for them some
specific research on a critical issue
that they're facing we work with a lot
of investors who are trying to
understand you know I see this
opportunity is this SE category going to
be as lucrative as this company that
we're about to invest in claims it's
going to be what is the long-term
trajectory of this market I'll give you
an example we just completed a project
with a group of Australian investors who
have phenomenal experience in the
agricultural sector that have never been
in cannabis before they were looking at
investment a fairly substantial
investment in a company that makes
cannabis nutrients and question was how
big is this market going to be in what
sort of potential capture opportunity
could this company take of that market
we did all about analysis and that
ultimately involved the investment
thesis and ultimately the investment
decision
we've worked with you know companies who
are looking at some of these emerging
state markets state like Florida's about
to go adult is about having a dog use
ballot initiative proposed for 2020 for
the investors who are looking at a large
market that has very likely strong
likelihood of passing early tests
suggest that that if a ballot to
introduce the day that there's a good
likelihood it could pause investors are
looking at that market and it's going to
be a lucrative one and where they're
wondering you know how largest
opportunity is specifically going to be
and what are some of the key dynamics we
should be looking out for as we try to
navigate that investment similarly on
our global scale and we've seen this
explosion and interest in CBD and
companies are now wondering you know how
does the global CBD supply chain work
how do we get involved where should we
be if we have the ability to set up
operations anywhere in the world which
countries it should be looking at and
what sort of assets should we be
investing in to ensure that we're not
planning for next year we're planning
five years from that for a market five
years from now so there's there's a lot
of you have public facing reports going
out but then there's also all these
incoming inquiries they're they're
really they're querying your knowledge
chief knowledge officer like they're
querying your knowledge so that they can
gain the insight so so then you work
with companies organizations
individually as well based on what they
want to know that's why so the data that
we make available through Acquia which
is our data platform and maybe the
simple way to think about it's like a
Bloomberg for cannabis industry
it houses not just the reports that we
produce but the data underlying the
reports if you want to go in and kind of
explore the data yourself you can
certainly do that
and so there's ability to kind of go
through the self-service model of you
know just taking the content that's
relevant to you and
kind of diving into our content
screaming capitalizing on that and then
for the for the stakeholders who are not
grappling with a very specific issue to
engage us to do much more customized and
nuanced analysis for for them you
mentioned this earlier that you guys
have so much data that is coming in I
mean we could talk about that but you
actually said that that's not as
challenging now as actually talking
about the stories of the why that data
matters after it does get structured and
so tell us about how you guys can take
up like a Pixar like a Disney role
regarding storytelling about the
profundity of the data and why it should
matter to the world that's that's a
great question and a really important
one based on where we are right now as a
cannabis industry and an ill-used
example of the cannabis consumer which
is where we think one of the greatest
opportunities for cannabis is beginning
to emerge so pre legalization the
cannabis consumer was a monolith you
either cannabis consumer or you weren't
post legalization be bifurcated the
cannabis consumers into either a medical
consumer or a recreational consumer but
as we're looking at the space to me that
just didn't feel right from all of the
consumers who were speaking to that that
duality that that simple duality just
was not reflective of the nuanced ways
in which consumers were interfacing and
integrating cannabis into their their
lives and lifestyles so in late 2018 we
deployed what at the time was the
largest cannabis consumer survey that
had ever been done nationally which was
based in the u.s. nationally national
scope including Bret create like fully
recreational medical and unregulated
markets and the question was we're
trying to understand who is the cannabis
consumer
based on this very very large survey I
mean it took our respondents nearly 30
minutes to complete we spent a lot of
time not just asking about their
cannabis usage habits the cannabis
experiences but other things about their
lives and lifestyle zone and what was
the sample size of this 4500 4500 Wow
across the u.s. across the US so by
statistical perk for statistical
purposes more than enough data for us to
do some really really elegant
segmentation 30 minutes is a big survey
- exactly exactly so we took actually
the questions I was an interviewer I
already know that you guys focusing on
the questions was again the one of the
most important parts of all of this
because then it leads you to what the
answers are what the data is that you
get so I assume you guys spent a
ridiculous amount of time on the
questions it was a month long like many
months long effort to build that survey
right because we knew that if we got it
right
the applications for that data
downstream would be potentially profound
let's hear it so once we got the data
back it became clear that this idea of
the medical recreational binary was just
completely incorrect and there was it
was much more of a fluid continuum
between kind of pure recreational
consumers blending into the wellness
consumer and then to the pure
pharmaceutical at me use of consumer
who's treating cannabis like any other
pharmaceutical drug the interesting
recreational blending with wellness
blending with augment replacement
Dinesen ago and just who totally
spectrum style between like that style
okay very cool but but there was a layer
of deep yeah which is we took nearly 200
data points out of survey and used it to
create consumer cluster so we basically
said take these 200 data points and
let's an algorithm identify the
groups that have a greatest affinity
with them and through that we developed
nine cannabis consumer archetypes
profiles of cannabis consumers that are
not just defined based on what they
consume and how they consume but based
on all of these other lifestyle
attributes as well that inform the usage
habits and inform their cannabis
consumer archetypes precisely Wow
and the archetypes fell across those
nine archetypes three that fell across
the highest using groups three that fell
across moderate use in groups with
across the lowest using groups but as we
explained these archetypes and and I'll
perhaps will give you a couple of
examples we have the traditional
lifestyle people who use cannabis very
very regularly but I'm much more likely
to be flower only smokers so these are
people who have integrated cannabis into
virtually everything they use it to get
up and go they use it to wind down at
the end of the day you know they are
kind of let's call them join today
consumers a kind of daily habitual
consumers but there are almost flower
only flower exclusive consumers and
they're much less likely to consume in
such products
contrast that against the modern
lifestyle others who have a very similar
usage profile but have completely
embraced the new value-added products so
these are considered like tic-tac the
1/2 milligram tic tacs
so they're you know not just using vapes
and edibles and teachers and well it's
this so consumed flower but much more
load balanced on these other types of
products and because they're using these
other types of products they're also
much more likely to use these products
in much more diversified ways it's like
the artisanal user oh they're like which
brand of this do you purchase of
cannabis you know and it's its idea that
maybe in the morning I'll use
CBD vape for one thing and then if I go
to the gym afternoon I'll use kind of
activating sativa after I'm done working
out I'll apply a CBD lotion on my sore
muscles and then before I go to bed I'll
have an indicator help me sleep and help
me stay asleep longer and so it's
extraordinary what the advent of these
new product forms has done for the way
cannabis is being used not just because
they allow for a lot more distract
description discretion you know you
can't smoke a joint in the restaurant or
a bar gonna being quickly escorted out
or even at a dinner party without people
freaking out but you know today's pop a
little tic tac at the party that's right
you can take a little edible you could
pull out a vape pen which some baits
have are so odorless now that literally
a person makes you could be consuming
and you wouldn't be able to tell yeah
well these archetypes are so interesting
and then there's the ones like we
interviewed Chris and priceless Aaron
Baker as well who are literally going
through some of the most rare diseases
as literally teenagers and then for them
to be able to take you know like
hundreds of milligrams of full spectrum
hemp CBD to heal themselves and to start
company is like so there's like that too
for look that was one of our archetypes
the medical purists consumers who truly
are using cannabis as a pharmaceutical
product and and you know there was
nothing social recreational about their
use very very regimented meticulous
about you know this is just a medicinal
product and so try to pitch them product
for going out hanging with your friends
we just have no resonance with them I
have a quick question on the way out the
last one actually the last question is
the emerging market is exploding how do
we make sure that the fruits of this
emerging market unlike past instances of
emerging markets how do these fruits
become more well democratized and
distributed across
minority populations across some
vulnerable populations women people of
color all type of stuff
just just democratize the financial
benefits more widely how can we ensure
something like that this is a great and
critical question because the window to
do that is actually closing and it's
closing quickly first there has to be a
conic conversation about some things I
mentioned earlier the inequity that
cannabis prohibition has had on the
state of the market today who's
participating in the market and who
feels that they can participate in the
market today there's a lot of people who
you know after being or recognizing that
any association with cannabis could get
them into deep deep trouble and that
they would be targeted for it getting
those people to switch their mindset to
now say that they're going to enter the
industry what takes work takes real
conversation for them to understand that
this is a real legitimate opportunity
and they're not going to face the
challenges that the previously faced the
second thing that businesses in the
space can do and should do is think
deeply about
how their practices are either
supporting these broader goals he
brought a rule around equity and
opportunity in the space or undermining
them so for example one of the biggest
challenges that minorities of people of
newer means have had participating in
cannabis is access to capital the fact
that cannabis is not banked at the
Federal Open the banks are not
participating this industry because of
its a leak in the Galatea federal level
has meant that much of this industry has
been largely privately funded and so the
people who have been able to participate
most robust the other people who have
access to a high net worth capital
unfortunately has meant that there's
been a great number of extraordinary
entrepreneurs with brilliant ideas who
because of lack of access to capital
have not been able to bring those ideas
to fruition and so there needs to be a
robust conversation about how some of
these regulatory practices and the
social environment that we're in our
problem propagating and promulgating
these these issues issues like the
advent of federal banking there's a bill
to just pass that four that was going to
that's intended to address this issue of
banking for cannabis businesses should
help more stakeholders find access to
capital in the space but I think
investors also need to challenge the
conventional assumptions about who can
be an opportunity to a successful
entrepreneur in this space because the
best given that cannabis consumers
represent the full cross-section of
society it is one of the true
egalitarian aspects products in our
economy
it's important for booth investors
business operators to understand that
because this is a product that
transcends our society it should be a
industry that reflects the spectrum of
society and we love asking at least this
question at the end of this show what do
you think is the most beautiful thing in
the world great question
a joyful spirit
and ironically it's something the
profundity of which I hadn't understood
until I came into the cannabis industry
and saw people who were more passionate
committed driven invested in their work
than any other sector I've ever worked
in I think it is a reason why despite
the phenomenal challenges this industry
faces I mean you talk out about a sector
that has headwinds coming from all
directions that it has been enabled to
the crew at the pace it has and it has
been able to achieve but because people
love what they do and at a time when
there's so much doom and gloom they so
much anxiety in public I think we would
all do well to find more joy in
ourselves and spark joy in each other
and I think that seems to be one of the
moods that we're driving commitments
that's pushing a lot of people in this
space John this has been such a
fascinating episode thank you so much
for coming on and teaching us it's been
my pleasure thank you for having me
thank you thank you keep up the great
work with new friends here it's so cool
your macro perspective on the emergent
mark is so fascinating thank you so so
cool thanks everyone for tuning in we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking check out the
links in the bio to John also check out
the links to the work of new frontier
data go check out all those links also
to new West Summit check out those links
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the organizations the leaders in your
communities and around the world and
support us and our show there links are
below and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world you love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
it's a wrap great job great job that was
so fun
[Music]